Michelle starts us off in Lincoln
Nebraska hi Michelle welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi Dave thanks for taking my
call
sure what's up well my husband is an
alcoholic and in 2011 he became
self-employed working construction which
has just enabled his drinking to
significantly increase we've spent our
savings to pay bills because his income
is inconsistent and his spending is very
consistent he spends on his wants before
our needs I work full-time and we keep
our money separate right now and I'm
just wondering you know I'm trying to do
whatever I can to protect myself
financially I'm wondering if you have
any advice on what I can do which
protect myself and my kids financially
and in the event of if I do decide to
move forward with the divorce if you
have any advice on that end as well um
so he drinks all day long Chum
yes how much I don't know all right how
long has this been going on
well thanks since he became
self-employed I'm fairly confident it's
been going on all day long since then
before that when he was what makes you
think what makes you think his drinking
is keeping him from working and he's not
just lazy oh he's working mm-hmm he's
working back yes I'll see him over the
noon hour and I can smell it on his
breath and he has had friends worked for
him and they have told me told you what
that is drinks okay on the job yes and
he'll drink all evening long he'll stay
up at night a drink so when you all
talked about this and talked about him
needing help for it what is his response
well in the last couple years you've
gotten a couple of DWI is in this last
one he decided he wanted to stay sober
so actually I should clarify right now
he is sober because of the DWI he has an
ankle monitor on that monitors is blood
alcohol content but I have very little
faith that he'll as soon as that comes
off that he'll stay shoulder so when
when does it come off probably another
year but in the meantime his behaviors
are the same I'm sure we're ending oh
spinning bending is the same it's just a
different shift on what he's spending it
on versus alcohol now okay well here's
the thing your marriages is a disaster
yep let's just say that out loud and
something's got to change for it to have
a chance to succeed and so the first
goal here is for you to go see a good
marriage counselor are you involved in a
church at all I'm the man sir do you
have a church in the area you trust yes
I well I just started going to a new
church yeah okay you need to call that
pastor today tell them what's going on
and tell him you need to sit down with a
marriage counselor your husband will or
may or may not go I don't care I mean I
care but that's not relevant you still
need to go sit down and talk to him
because you need to develop a series of
ultimatums that are put in front of him
that clearly define for him what going
forward with you looks like if we don't
do these things we're not going forward
okay and that has to be very clear it
can't be subtle because what happens in
a situation like yours is you finally
get so fed up that a switch flips and
you're over it and there's no getting
you back no matter what yeah and I'm not
there yeah and you're just you're
boiling to the point of exploding and so
you need to sub while you still got a
little bit of calm left you need to say
kidoh here's the deal this date these
steps marriage counseling
you know Financial Peace University
learning the budget and communicate
together steady work no more alcohol
ever plugging into Alcoholics Anonymous
while you're sober these are steps you
know you make them up I'm making them up
here I'm going to saying those are the
ones but you and the counselor together
make up a series of things that you
require of him that create healing in
him and in your marriage and in that and
that's the requirement for you to be
able to go forward and you you know
you'd have to lay that out very very
clearly in your mind and in his mind and
then him not doing those things as him
choosing to end the marriage okay and
that's what you've got to lay out now
because here's the thing continuing
forward in the land of crazy makes
everybody crazy you're as crazy as he is
two years from now follow me mm-hmm
and you're going to because he's crazy
and we're all crazy sometimes by the way
and but you know if you live with crazy
long enough you're crazy too oh yeah are
you with him are you in stay in the soup
okay so you you there is no such thing
as me answering your question that says
what can I do financially protect myself
from an addict of a husband answer is
you can't financially protect yourself
from a husband or spouse that is an
addict 100 percent of addicts that do
not seek and get help crash every
relationship in their life and crash
their finances 100 percent of the time
it's just a matter of how long it takes
any and as long as you're married to him
he's going to take you with them down
the toilet if he doesn't get better so
there is no middle ground in this game
there is we either get better or we get
gone over some period of reasonable
forgiveness and time okay the good news
is he's actually volunteered into this
ankle bracelet that's really hopeful
news in this situation it's the only
thing hopeful in the entire conversation
yes it is and so you can build on that
as what I'm hoping and okay honey I see
you're trying to get better now let's
work on this because I'm about at my end
of my patience or
forgiveness or whatever you want to call
it right and and so for while we got you
sober let's talk this through here's
what we've got to do for me to be able
to stick through this because I'm not
going to go back to the old ways when
the bracelet comes off and and I'm kind
of afraid that's what's going to happen
right now I have no reason to believe
it's not going to be so you got to give
me a reason to believe and here's the
things we're going to do and talk that
through with a counselor not with a
radio host all right and that's how we
suggest you do it and then if God forbid
you go through a divorce then sadly the
divorce turns a marriage into a business
transaction and it's just a negotiation
of who gets what at that point and
hopefully any debts that have your name
on them get paid out in the divorce but
it doesn't sound like there's a lot of
money laying around in this situation to
pay a bunch of stuff so you're going to
have a hard time after the divorce is
probably what you're facing but not near
as hard as you'll have being married to
an addict for the next ten years so
hopefully we can turn this you can turn
this around though thanks for the call
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you